[Musique]
la nuit d'halloween 1963 à haddonfield
dans l'illinois
michael myers alors âgée de 6 ans
assassiné de sang-froid sa propre soeur
mais ce n'est que 15 ans plus tard lors
de la nuit d'halloween 1978 que la
légende de michael myers est née après
s'être échappé de l'hôpital
psychiatrique
il est retourné à haddonfield
où il a sauvagement assassiné des
résidentes son quartier seule la jeune
laurie strode avait survécu alors laurie
après toutes ces années
qu'est ce qui selon vous a poussé
michael à commettre tous ses moeurs
[Musique]
vous croyez pas aux crocs bethel non
vous devriez dans cette ville michael
myers est un mythe une histoire pour
effrayer les enfants
mais ce croque les thèmes
et il est de retour michael mayer s'est
échappé six teintes vert
essayez le qui sera tuée cette nuit
j'ai fermé la porte
[Musique]